[Music]
on this wednesday night inflation
frustration
canada's cost of living keeps climbing i
don't know how i can handle the highest
inflation rate in three decades and
what's compounding problems for people
tight on cash
new military reinforcements to resist
russia canada's commitment to help
ukraine systemic racism infecting
canadian healthcare we get asked
immediately like are you on drugs the
fight for equality
plus raised to the rafters
honoring william reed the canadian
hockey player who broke the nhl's color
barrier
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight sophie louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
new data from statistics canada is
confirming what many canadians have
likely already noticed the cost of
living in this country is going up fast
inflation hit 4.8 percent last month the
highest in three decades to put that in
perspective back in 1991 brian mulrooney
was canada's prime minister george bush
senior was the u.s president and the
soviet union ceased to exist we are
paying more for food transportation and
housing and after nine straight months
of rising inflation economists warn the
streak may not be over as ann gaviola
explains in tonight's top story that
could force the bank of canada to
respond as early as next week
this container used to be 75
right now 145
michelle lee has been in the restaurant
business for more than 30 years but
she's never dealt with a perfect storm
like this labor shortages rising wages
omicron restrictions and inflation we
lock down
and i don't know how i can end it
overall year over year inflation was 4.8
percent in december the biggest drivers
transportation costs rising nearly nine
percent shelter up 5.4 percent and food
going up by 5.2 percent
the prime minister was advised last
february most forecasters do not expect
inflation to accelerate beyond the bank
of canada's three percent target in the
next few years according to a memo
obtained by global news through federal
access to information law well less than
a year later inflation's been pushing
five percent for months now the
opposition's finance critic blames the
government's spending and stimulus
saying the u.s is dealing with raging
inflation for the same reason
the americans have seven percent
inflation
why because of their stupid monetary and
fiscal policy it's that simple they're
running massive deficits and printing
money to pay for it but economists say
global factors specifically massive
supply chain snarls are bigger culprits
which means that even if the bank of
canada hikes rates earlier than expected
monetary policy may not effectively cool
inflation there is little that the bank
of canada can do to address the biggest
part of the inflation puzzle and that is
the pandemic induced supply chain
disruptions the bank of canada has said
it would likely raise rates this spring
or summer markets are priced for a
january hike if they don't do it in
january the reason why is because they
really want to make sure that everyone
is prepared for it regardless of when
the first rate hike comes canadians may
need to factor this kind of inflation
into household budgets for the
foreseeable future a tall order for
those already struggling to make ends
meet ann gaviola global news toronto
ukraine's allies are uniting behind the
country in the face of russia's military
buildup along its borders today u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken met
with president vladimir zelinsky in kiev
promising to find a diplomatic solution
to the standoff but he warned there will
be a cost if russia tries to invade or
destabilize its neighbor michael couture
reports on how canada and others are
uniting in support of ukraine and
putting pressure on the kremlin
it's the arsenal that couldn't arrive
soon enough for ukraine british
anti-tank weapons and other military aid
is now on the ground in ukraine much to
the relief of the country's deputy
defense minister who insisted they will
only be used in self-defense the kremlin
claims that delivery of arms is adding
to the tension in the region even though
russia moved new battle helicopters to a
base near the country's border with
ukraine where intelligence estimates
125 000 russian troops are already
stationed that gives
president putin the capacity
also on very short notice
to take further aggressive action
canadian naval frigate hmcs montreal
left halifax today as part of nato's
operation reassurance signaling canada's
ongoing commitment to deterrence in the
mediterranean and black sea prime
minister justin trudeau says russia is
looking for excuses to escalate its
aggression we are standing there with
diplomatic responses
with sanctions
with
a full press on the international stage
to ensure that russia respects the
people of ukraine that same message is
coming from germany's olaf schultz for
years his predecessor angela merkel was
a strong voice willing to stand up to
vladimir putin the new chancellor was
blunt about our commitment to ukraine's
territorial integrity and about a key
principle of our common european peace
order
that borders must not be moved by force
schultz has signaled economic sanctions
are possible like cutting off the german
import of gas from russia the germany
could do a lot more should do a great
deal more in this case because
ultimately an evasion of ukraine
would be a threat to all the countries
on the continent western allies continue
to say russian aggression is
unacceptable but that was the message in
2014
when putin annexed crimea too
mike lacouter global news ottawa
well canada already has a large
contingent of troops in europe but what
more can this country do to help deter
russia our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson joins us now mercedes what
kind of support is ukraine asking for
sophie ukraine is looking for a way to
deter an invasion and if that's not
possible to at least slow one down
putting western boots on the ground in
eastern ukraine is one strategic option
planting the canadian flag as far east
as possible with something like military
trainers or observers could be enough to
make russia think twice the troops
wouldn't need to be there to fight the
mere presence of western soldiers could
mean russia runs the risk of triggering
a significant nato military response
whether that's something the canadian
government would consider contributing
to is unclear canada would only
participate in a combat operation if
there was an american-led coalition
formed that could include anything from
canadian infantry to fighter jets
medical support or surveillance right
now there are nearly 1 000 canadian
troops deployed to the region
780 canadian armed forces personnel are
deployed in operation reassurance in
europe there are also 200 canadian
troops in ukraine as part of operation
unifier helping to train the canadian
pardon me the ukrainian military 240
sailors are on hmcs montreal as mike
just mentioned in his report and 540
soldiers are on a standing presence
mission in latvia the canadian special
operations forces are also on the ground
in ukraine looking at options to support
the ukrainian government and contingency
planning to evacuate canadian personnel
if necessary
all right mercedes what are the
political considerations at play here
the calculus is really not just about
defending ukraine sophie it's about
signaling support to our biggest ally
the americans and the very influential
presence of deputy prime minister
christian freeland who has taken a
strong stance against russia and of
course the large voting bloc of
ukrainian canadians here at home who
want the government to act
all right thanks for that mercedes
stevenson in ottawa the u.s president
also weighing in with a warning for
russia if it invades ukraine in
washington tonight joe biden said the
country will face sanctions unlike
anything it has seen before
this is not all just a cake walk
for russia militarily they have
overwhelming superiority but they'll pay
a stiff price
immediately
near term medium term and long term if
they do it
now president biden made those comments
at a news conference marking his first
year in office the ukraine crisis is by
no means the only challenge he is
dealing with jackson prosco joins me now
from washington jackson the biden
administration is facing some serious
struggles at the moment
that's right sophie you know one year in
and the president's agenda has
effectively stalled his administration
has struggled to bring the pandemic
under control as the delta and omicron
variants have swept across this country
biden's signature plan known as build
back better is effectively dead at this
point and even measures like voting
rights protections which are hugely
popular with his own base don't actually
have enough support from elected
democrats to pass that leaves the
president entering his second year
looking for a complete reset and today
he hinted he's going to do that by
taking a run at his republican opponents
who have openly blocked so much of his
agenda what are republicans for
what are they for
they mean one thing they're for
and so
the problem here is that i think what
happens what i have to do
and the and the change in
tactic if you will
i have to make clear to the american
people
what we are for so i tell my republican
friends here i come
jackson the midterm elections are less
than 300 days away how much trouble are
biden and the democrats in right now
you know the polls are abysmal right now
68 percent of americans in a recent
survey think the country is currently
headed in the wrong direction and
biden's own approval rating sits at just
40 percent that's in the ballpark of the
historically unpopular donald trump who
came before him now when it comes to
turning things around there's a sense
that americans simply want direct
measurable and competent action which
could actually explain a sudden shift in
pandemic policy from the white house as
of today at home rapid test kits can
actually be ordered for free online to
any home in the country and the
administration is also taking the step
of making 400 million n95 masks
available for free these are the types
of relatively simple measures that even
biden's own supporters argue he should
have been doing months ago sophie
jackson proskow in washington thanks
jackson now to the covid situation in
canada in ontario health minister
christine elliott says there are
glimmers of hope in the fight to get
control of the omicron fueled fifth wave
we are beginning to see signs of
stabilization
omicron cases are expected to peak this
month new hospitalizations are slowing
and are now doubling closer to every two
weeks
ontario is expected to announce a
gradual easing of restrictions in the
coming days although the province is
warning february will likely be another
challenging month with hospitals still
dealing with the impacts of that fifth
wave
in england the government says it
appears the omicron wave has now peaked
and it is ready to start easing
restrictions starting next thursday face
masks in public places and proof of
vaccination will no longer be required
the government is also immediately
scrapping the advice to work from home
the british health minister says efforts
to blunt the impacts of omicron have
worked he warns however that people must
learn to live with kovid the same way we
live with the flu well critics of boris
johnson say they don't have to live with
him as their prime minister though
in the name of god go
coming up the growing calls to quit
plus city switcher why indonesia is
getting a new capital
there's new trouble for british prime
minister boris johnson after accusations
he lied about lockdown parties today one
of his own mps defected to the
opposition and a veteran conservative mp
and former cabinet minister joined calls
for his resignation
i expect my leaders
to shoulder the responsibility
for the actions they take so i'll remind
him of a quotation altogether too
familiar to him of leo amory to neville
chamberlain you have sat there too long
for all the good you have done in the
name of god go
johnson responded by defending his
government's record but pressure to step
down is growing a minimum of 54
conservative mps must submit formal
letters of no confidence to trigger a
vote on his leadership it's unclear
exactly how many have been written so
far although a handful of mps have
openly called for his resignation
phone service is being restored in tonga
after that massive undersea volcanic
eruption over the weekend new images are
giving us a better idea of the damage
that cut off communication to the rest
of the world entire homes have been
destroyed with debris scattered across
communities international calling has
apparently been restored but internet
connections could take over a month to
fix
indonesia's government has approved a
bill to relocate its capital it will be
called nusantara that translates to
archipelago fitting for a country made
up of more than 17 000 islands
construction can now get underway on the
island of borneo about 2000 kilometers
away from the current capital jakarta
jakarta is densely populated and
congested and it's sinking at an
alarming rate it was built on swamp land
and the over-extraction of groundwater
has caused more than 40 percent of the
city to sink below sea level the first
phase of the government's move to new
suntara could begin in 2024.
racism in canadian healthcare ahead the
barriers indigenous patients face
a steady stream of drivers gassed up in
merit bc today as the major highway
connecting the interior to metro
vancouver reopened to regular traffic
just two months ago catastrophic
flooding destroyed more than 100
kilometers of the coquihalla highway
between hope and merit crews worked
around the clock to reopen the route
first to commercial traffic in just 35
days and today to the rest of the public
the city of iqaluit has shut down its
water treatment plant after fuel was
again discovered in the supply the city
says a breach was found in the system
last week and again today after
residents reported a fuel smell in the
tap water iqaluit was under a boil water
advisory for two months last year for
the same issue
indigenous people have long said they
are not taken seriously in canada's
healthcare system and now there is data
to back that up a study analyzing
millions of emergency room visits in
alberta found indigenous patients were
treated as less urgent even if their
complaints were the same as other
patients as heather urex west reports
advocates hope this research will help
combat systemic racism
pamela bibi has spent much of her
professional life advocating for truth
and reconciliation but in her personal
life she's had to spend a great deal of
time advocating for her family's health
care when somebody has to go to the
emergency room and get sent home right
away nobody is surprised in my family we
get asked immediately like are you on
drugs are you high why are your eyes red
like all these questions around that are
just not appropriate baby is not alone
and now new research published in the
canadian medical association journal has
found evidence that indigenous people
consistently experience discrimination
within alberta emergency rooms so some
real
hard quantitative data that systemic
racism exists that's right exactly using
data from alberta hospitals researchers
found first nations routinely receive
lower acuity triage scores important
because patients with higher scores are
given a higher priority for care what
happens
from the data that we see
is that people who are from the first
nations community are put down lower in
the list
to be seen for those same types of
injuries as people who are not from the
first nations community the alberta
research adds to a growing body of
evidence that systemic anti-indigenous
racism in health care is a national
problem we found pervasive interpersonal
systemic racism a 2020 inquiry found 84
percent of indigenous patients
experienced discrimination within bc's
health system
and of course no one can forget the
tragic death of joyce eshequan
the attica woman died in a quebec
hospital days after live streaming this
video on her chart a nurse had
identified her as a drug abuser in
withdrawal it wasn't true it makes us
very reticent to access
healthcare services and we don't do so
unless we absolutely have to whether
it's the researchers in the alberta
study the coroner's report in quebec or
the inquiry in bc the key
recommendations are the same systemic
racism within the canadian healthcare
system exists and a reckoning is overdue
whether they're nurses doctors
respiratory therapists security guards
everybody needs
to gain skills and how to
address their bias and be aware of it in
order to ensure all indigenous people
have equitable access to care heather
urex west global news calgary
more than just a number next the hockey
world honors a canadian who changed the
game
the woman known as the queen of
basketball has died lucia harris is the
only woman drafted by an nba team she's
also the first player to score in
olympic women's basketball history
sinking the first basket in the 1976
montreal games harris went on to become
the first black woman inducted into the
basketball hall of fame she's being
remembered for her charity and what she
did both on and off the court harris was
66.
another sports pioneer was honored by
the nhl last night willie o'reilly the
league's first black player had his
jersey retired by the boston bruins as
mike trelay reports even without a
lengthy nhl career his impact on hockey
can still be felt on and off the ice
[Music]
it's fair to say william's expectations
never included seeing his jersey retired
by the boston bruins maybe not even his
dreams as a young man growing up in the
1950s his sole focus was on just making
it to the nhl all i wanted was to be a
hockey player
all i needed was the opportunity
he was so overwhelmed when the bruins
called him up in 1958 he only learned he
had made history as the first black man
to play in the nhl the following day it
was the greatest thrill of my life i
believe i'll always remember this day in
the first period you look like you're a
little nervous were you yes i bet it
scared you a little bit yes it did anno
reed goes back for boston oh ree would
play 45 games over two seasons before
embarking on a successful career in the
minor leagues it was never easy
yeah i heard the racial remarks and
racial slurs and it was in chicago and
new york probably the the worst problems
i had like baseball's jackie robinson
before him he endured in relative
silence in fact he never told any of his
teams that an errant puck had left him
blind in one eye for fear they wouldn't
let him play
and while his nhl career was short 45
games in all his impact is almost
impossible to gauge countless minorities
now play hockey because of outreach
programs he helped build and former
nhler george larocque says he never
fails to give a re-credit when speaking
to children
i always talk about the history of the
game and to me it's always so important
to tell them that you know what
i know you guys looked up to me but if
it wasn't for him you wouldn't have
never seen me play sadly racism still
permeates the hockey world it's a
reality the nhl is working to change
seeing the jersey go up is a reminder to
people that it wasn't just white people
who played hockey
there are lots of other
cultures and races
that are playing hockey
and
that we need to be inclusive and that
would be a dream legacy for william rhee
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm sophie louie
tonight's your canada is cavendish beach
on the north shore of prince edward
island there are beautiful spots all
over canada please email us yours to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and have a good
night